-On accuse parfois les responsables
politiques d'être hors-sol.
Dur de faire ce reproche
à mon invitée,
elle a connu quatre métiers
différents les uns des autres
avant d'ajouter
une dernière ligne à son CV,
celle de députée
de la majorité présidentielle.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Brigitte Liso.
-Bonjour, Clément Méric.
-Vous êtes une députée
plutôt discrète,
vous cherchez pas la lumière
mais lors du débat sur la réforme
des retraites,
on a vu une autre
Brigitte Liso,
très en colère
quand un député communiste
a reproché à la majorité
de ne rien y connaître au travail.
On regarde.
*-En termes de travail,
je crois que nous n'avons pas
de leçon à recevoir.
J'ai commencé
à travailler à 18 ans,
j'ai eu quatre métiers
différents.
Protestations vives
...
J'ai une mère qui a commencé
à travailler à 15 ans,
elle a aujourd'hui...
Elle s'est arrêtée à 65 ans.
Si vous calculez,
ça fait 55 ans de travail.
Elle a aujourd'hui 90 ans,
alors s'il vous plaît,
les leçons,
vous les gardez.
Merci.
Applaudissements
-On sent que cette attaque
de l'opposition,
elle a touché une corde
sensible en vous.
-Ah oui, là,
c'est tout ce que je suis,
tout ce que je représente,
ma famille, la valeur travail
est une valeur essentielle chez moi,
et là, ils ont piqué juste là
où il ne fallait pas.
-Tout au long
de votre vie,
vous avez enchaîné des métiers
très différents,
vous commencez à 18 ans
comme démonstratrice
en supermarché
pour Pernod Ricard,
vous avez ensuite été commerciale
chez Hachette,
visiteuse médicale
pour un grand laboratoire
pharmaceutique,
vous avez tenu
un restaurant à Lille
et ouvert une pâtisserie
spécialisée
dans les éclairs.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit de vous,
ce parcours professionnel ?
-Ca dit de moi que rien
n'est impossible
quand on a un peu
d'audace et de courage,
des opportunités de vie,
aussi, puisque les choses
sont venues progressivement
à moi, je les ai remarquées
et je me suis engouffrée
à chaque fois dans une autre vie,
un autre métier.
-Y a aussi l'idée
de relever des défis,
sortir un peu
d'une zone de confort ?
Ca vous plaît, ça ?
-Oui, c'est exactement ça,
peut-être aussi éviter la lassitude
à un moment et aller là
où on ne m'attend pas
et où je ne pensais pas aller.
-Là où on ne vous attendait pas,
effectivement,
c'est la politique.
Après ces vies
professionnelles, vous avez répondu
à l'appel lancé par Macron,
appel à la société civile en 2017,
et vous avez décidé
de briguer l'investiture
aux législatives, à Lille.
La politique, avant cela,
elle occupait quelle place
dans votre vie ?
-Alors, euh,
une conscience politique
de toujours,
mais la politique, pour moi,
je la faisais depuis mon canapé,
avec des idées
très précises et arrêtées,
en me disant que c'était quand même
fou qu'une telle décision
ait été prise sans savoir
ce que vivent les Français,
etc., vous voyez.
-Avec une sensibilité de gauche ?
-Plutôt de gauche, oui.
-Vous avez été
investie pour La République
En Marche à Lille
aux législatives.
Face au vieux routier
de la politique
qui était face à vous,
vous avez fait de votre inexpérience
un argument de campagne.
Pourquoi ?
Vous avez senti
que ça pouvait répondre
à une attente des électeurs ?
-Parce que c'était aussi la réalité,
je n'étais pas une politique
attendue, ni formatée,
en revanche,
j'avais mon expérience
de vie pour moi et ça répondait
aussi à une demande,
à un désir d'Emmanuel Macron
de changer
un peu les comportements
et de changer
la politique.
-Et ça répondait
à une attente des gens ?
Vous l'avez ressenti ?
-Ils étaient un peu déstabilisés
car certains se disaient :
si elle le fait,
je peux peut-être aussi le faire.
Et là, c'est aussi un message
que j'ai pu envoyer,
involontairement,
mais aussi inconsciemment
aux femmes,
rien n'est impossible,
et puis, y a aussi
toute l'autre partie,
les politiques locaux bien implantés
qui ont vu débarquer
une femme pas si jeune,
en plus,
qui a un peu bousculé
quand même les habitudes.
-Comment ça s'est passé ?
Vos adversaires
vous ont prise de haut ?
-Ah, ça, je peux vous dire
qu'on m'attendait en ricanant.
-Ouais.
-Et puis j'ai donné
ce que j'avais à donner,
c'est-à-dire ma personne
telle que je suis.
Et, bah, le résultat a été,
effectivement,
j'ai été élue,
assez largement d'ailleurs.
-J'ai lu que certains
de vos adversaires
vous appelaient la vendeuse
d'éclairs de Lille.
-C'est possible, ou la pâtissière.
Alors j'essayais de démentir
tout simplement
parce que je ne suis pas pâtissière
et que c'est un métier
tout à fait respectable,
mais ça n'était pas le cas.
Mais peu importe.
-Vous avez été élue sur cette idée
du renouvellement,
mais pas seulement,
aussi sur l'idée de faire
de la politique différemment.
Si on devait faire le bilan,
quelques années plus tard,
est-ce que vous avez vraiment fait
de la politique différemment ?
-Euh,
alors y a deux stades,
enfin, deux points de vue,
y a le mien
et puis peut-être
la politique nationale qui...
-Mais vous, personnellement,
qu'avez-vous apporté
de différent ?
-Moi, j'ai apporté mon passé
de citoyenne lambda,
et ça, c'est quelque chose
que je n'oublie pas,
quelque chose qui vit avec moi
et j'ai encore quelquefois
ce réflexe de dire :
mais non, c'est pas comme ça,
les Français
ne réagiraient pas comme ça.
Alors après,
effectivement, moi,
je suis prise dans un grand groupe,
donc, quelquefois, les idées
que l'on émet ne sont pas retenues.
Et puis, là, j'ai une certaine
loyauté mais là aussi,
je la tire de mes expériences
professionnelles, vous savez,
vous avez parlé d'un grand
groupe pharmaceutique, en effet,
on porte le groupe individuellement.
-Une fois élue,
vos premiers pas
à l'Assemblée ont été
un peu compliqués.
Une journaliste radio est venue
vous interroger sur la première loi
du quinquennat,
la loi travail,
en vous demandant
ce que vous compreniez
de cette réforme
et votre réponse a été confuse.
*-On a beaucoup parlé
de la version de...
Attendez.
La version de...
Pour quelqu'un comme moi
qui est assez direct,
qui va vite à l'essentiel,
quelquefois,
je suis un peu perdue...
Les salles de commission...
La version de la...
*-C'est des échanges de textos ?
*-Oui, ça,
c'est la boucle Telegram.
Alors, là,
c'est les députés du Nord...
Bon, écoutez, je ne trouve plus,
donc on va laisser tomber.
Alors, votre autre question ?
-Vous dites vous-même que ça a été
un baptême du feu un peu violent
et douloureux.
-Mais, vous savez,
je ne l'ai pas réécouté
depuis un bon moment
et j'entends ça
avec beaucoup de tendresse.
Alors, effectivement,
je ne suis pas un grand tribun
- je vais pas dire tribune !
-Absence totale de langue de bois,
là, on est d'accord.
-Voilà,
y a pas de langue de bois
et aussi, alors,
je vais pas passer trop de temps
sur ce sujet,
mais aussi un contexte :
on était venu visiter mon bureau,
c'était mes...
-Vous vous attendiez pas
à être interrogée comme ça.
-Pas du tout et la formule était
de m'auto-poser des questions.
Ca faisait beaucoup de choses,
voilà, et puis c'était un épisode.
-Vous en avez tiré une leçon,
vis-à-vis des médias en général ?
-Oui, peut-être de la méfiance,
j'étais quand même un peu piégée,
c'est un sujet qui a été diffusé
plusieurs mois après
l'enregistrement,
effectivement, au mois d'octobre,
je n'aurais pas
répondu de cette façon.
-Ce qui peut
ressortir aussi de ça,
c'est que votre inexpérience
a été un atout
pendant la campagne,
ça a pas été une faiblesse
comme députée ?
-Là encore, je vous dis,
c'était les 15 premiers jours,
mais probablement,
comme entrer dans un nouveau monde,
une nouvelle entreprise,
y a des codes
que l'on doit s'approprier.
C'était peut-être un peu tôt.
-En 2018,
vous expliquez que
vous ne visiez pas de ministère
et vantez votre absence d'ambition
personnelle, hein,
pas politique :
"Je fais un travail de fourmi",
expliquiez-vous.
C'est louable mais,
en politique,
est-ce que c'est pas aussi
une erreur que d'être
toujours dans l'ombre ?
Est-ce qu'il faut pas s'affirmer,
se montrer,
pour avoir un peu de poids,
dans les débats ?
-Je crois
que c'est une micro-société,
le monde politique,
et on peut pas tous
prendre la lumière,
on a pas tous ce désir-là.
Moi, je ne fais pas partie
de ces personnes-là,
je pourrai aussi encore
vous dire que je n'ai pas
d'ambition politique,
je n'attends pas de ministère.
-Mais vous avez l'ambition
de changer les choses.
-Mais je suis une députée de terrain
et les choses, je les change,
même si elles n'apparaissent pas
dans les vidéos TikTok,
ou dans les émissions du soir.
On arrive à changer les choses
en étant une députée de terrain
et en remontant les sujets locaux
à l'Assemblée.
-Vous dites en 2017 :
"Je ne voterai jamais une loi
"avec laquelle
je ne suis pas d'accord."
Un an plus tard,
léger changement de ton,
vous dites n'avoir pas
toujours été en adéquation
parfaite avec les lois
qui étaient proposées.
C'est le métier
qui est rentré ?
C'est l'apprentissage de...
-Oui.
-...de la politique ?
-Y a certainement de ça
et encore, là, je vous dis,
quand on fait partie d'un groupe,
on y va.
Après,
y a toujours cette possibilité,
dans le jargon de l'Assemblée,
on dit qu'on a piscine,
parfois, donc on est absent.
-Ca, ça vous est arrivé,
vous avez appris à vous fondre
dans les codes de la politique
à l'ancienne, finalement...
-Finalement,
c'est un peu ça mais,
d'un autre côté, des lois,
on en vote assez peu,
on vote énormément
au cours d'une session,
mais des lois,
y en a relativement peu.
Donc on peut aussi
ne pas voter des articles,
ne pas voter des amendements,
c'est aussi une forme d'expression.
-Aux législatives de 2022,
vous pouvez plus jouer la carte
du renouvellement,
de l'inexpérience.
Vous étiez plus la vendeuse
d'éclairs qui se lance en politique
mais la députée sortante.
L'expérience,
ça a du bon ?
Vous avez joué cette carte ?
-J'ai joué la carte de l'expérience
et j'ai eu aussi en retour
cette expérience,
c'est-à-dire que je n'étais plus
regardée de la même façon
et j'étais vraiment la sortante.
Effectivement, ça aide beaucoup.
-On va passer à notre quiz,
c'est pas compliqué,
je vous explique,
vous allez devoir compléter
les phrases que je vais commencer.
-Allez-y.
-Un bon député,
c'est comme un bon
chef pâtissier,
il doit ?
-Il doit mettre
la main à la pâte !
-Et respecter...
respecter le dosage
des ingrédients,
aussi, en politique ?
-Oui,
peut-être, peut-être,
mais on peut être aussi créatif.
-A l'Assemblée, tout est devenu
plus simple quand j'ai compris que ?
-Quand j'ai compris que, euh,
on ne jouait pas sa vie
à tous les moments.
-Parce que, au début,
vous aviez peur...
-C'était pas une peur,
mais c'était vraiment,
le rôle de député
est très important pour moi,
porter par exemple une écharpe,
tous ces symboles-là...
-Ca pouvait
vous paralyser dans votre action ?
-Bah j'avais un tel respect,
une telle image de ce rôle
que ça pouvait peut-être
me déstabiliser.
-Enfin, deux mandats, ça va,
trois mandats ?
-Ah, on verra !
-Bonjour les dégâts ?
Pourquoi pas ?
-Pourquoi pas ?
Pourquoi pas.
-Très bien, on suivra ça.
Merci, Brigitte Liso.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...